bonjour françois al bacha merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu en coopération inédite entre à
la syrie et le liban si aujourd'hui le
liban elle se tourne vers son voisin
syrien c'est qu'il n'a plus d'autre
choix
bonjour tout d'abord c'est un plan
américain ça a été présentée tout en
premier par les américains ce qui a été
proposé en fait pas la part
l'ambassadrice des états unis au liban
le rôti shia qu'il avait présenté aux
autorités libanaises qui avaient été
très étonnant il ya deux semaines trois
semaines en raison justement du contexte
qui a été expliqué dans la vidéo
puisqu'il s'agit aussi surtout de de
permettre le financement de ce plan par
la banque mondiale et les américains ont
contacté notamment les égyptiens les
jordaniens et on sait pas comment ça
s'est passé avec la syrie mais la syrie
de là dedans joue un jeu très
intéressant sur le plan politique parce
qu'à la fois elle reçoit le fioul à
destination du liban par le plus iranien
à destination du liban est aussi
elle joue le rôle de roxie pour le
passage du gaz à destination du liban
donc il y as me connaissez ma joue le
rôle d'un tueur de roi là dessus alors
vous le dit hein damas à son intérêt a
très certainement dans dans cette
coopération à vous dit que tout ça était
un petit peu monté par les par les états
unis quel est l'intérêt américain
justement dans cette coopération entre
le liban et la syrie
c'est proposer justement une sorte d'
échanges avec la syrie peut être
du genre et l'éloigné un peu de l'iran
et permettent comme ça à la syrie de
reprendre une sono place ce sera
difficile cela dit au sein de la
communauté internationale puisque la
guerre civile est pratiquement déjà
terminée sauf qu'on voit aussi
aujourd'hui une reprise des combats au
niveau du bus de la région sud de la
syrie où justement parce ce fameux
gazoduc alors vous le dit un instant là
si rien n'est toujours pas un pays très
sécurisé est ce que toutes les
infrastructures
est-ce que tout est sécurisé et plus ou
moins pour faciliter les échanges entre
entre les pays
entre le liban et la syrie à peu près
oui mais le problème c'est quand dans la
région de la partie sud de la syrie au
niveau de daraa où les combats ont
repris
d'après ce que je sais c'est que les
infrastructures ont été assez
assez bien endommagée il n'y a pas
seulement le gazon de vue qui passe par
l'allemagne a aussi le réseau de il ya
un réseau en fête régionale
d'électricité qui passent par là bas qui
a été très endommagé aussi il s'agit
aussi que pour la jordanie de fournir de
l'électricité au liban via la syrie
est-ce que aussi c'est une avancée
diplomatique entre entre les deux pays
est ce qu'on peut espérer dans un avenir
plus ou moins proche de nouveaux
échanges entre syriens et libanais
des échanges cela dit on a toujours eu
lyon légaux et illégaux puisque on a
beaucoup une partie de la crise des
carburants qu'on connaît aujourd'hui au
liban a été induit justement par des
phénomènes de contrebande vers la syrie
et la syrie à utiliser quand même le
liban comme plateforme pour ses pour ses
industries et terra qui était confronté
aussi un régime de sanctions américaines
donc il ya eu toujours des des échanges
mais c'était en
sous la table par contre le projet de la
chose la plus intéressant c'est de voir
qu'au liban on a une sorte de
le silence de l'opposition anti-syrienne
là dessus et on a notamment vu chose que
les médias locaux n'ont pas n'ont pas
tellement
mis en lumière mais on a notamment vu le
premier ministre hariri qui tient damas
comme responsable de la mort de son père
rafic dire en egypte que grosso modo
cette importation est nécessaire de gaz
est ce que cela va permettre justement
de diminuer la facture
des carburants entre 50 et 60 % pour
l'électricité du livre justement c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez comment on
accueille cette coopération justement
olibeau on sait que les relations avec
les seuils sont sont assez compliqué
mais on sait que la situation est
dramatique 1 au liban aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya des partis qui sont
toujours très opposé un tout contact
avec la syrie
mais il ya quand même une réalité qui
doit s'imposer aussi parce que on peut
plus continuer comme ça les hôpitaux
manquent de fioul le libanais manque
d'électricité il ya des services qui
sont publiques qui sont menacés
d'effondrement la distribution de l'eau
notamment les hôpitaux toujours avec les
services de réanimation et ainsi de
suite donc c'est parti là
ils se taisent
et la presse locale ne fait pas
tellement
mansion 2 par contre les partis dits pro
syrien bien sûr salue cette ouverture et
ainsi de suite
l'accès en même temps sur la syrie
permet aussi de rouvrir un accès vers
miracle et vers le monde arabe
donc ça permet aussi au liban de
respirer au top économiquement cependant
dans ce compte dont on a bon beaucoup
besoin aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
françois el bacha d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin sur arte france rappelle que
vous en prie économiste et fondateur de
lebanese merci beaucoup